today I'd like to talk about a
collaborative model today I'd like to
talk about a collaborative model for
bioinformatics education combining
biologically inspired bioinformatics
with project-based learning and this
presentation is based on a collaboration
between Pine biotech and the Loyola
University of New Orleans specifically a
new class and bioinformatics that was
organized by dr. Kim mix and other
faculty for students that do not have a
background bioinformatics but were
interested to join this independent
study and learn about basics of
bioinformatics in the context of
project-based learning so I want to
start by pointing out that there is a
dramatic gap between our ability to
generate very precise high-throughput
data and then our ability to analyze
interpret and apply that data and this
is a growing gap particularly because
more and more data is being generated
it's cheaper to generate data and it's
useful to generate data however the
typical approach is that then once the
data is generated it is being taken to
an analyst somebody that sits at a
bioinformatics Department does not know
about how the data was generated and
doesn't know why was generated and this
data is presented to them explained to
them by somebody that speaks a
completely different language and that's
why there was recently several studies
that were talking about the gap in the
skills and the basic skills that are
necessary for basic data stewardship
that they're only being taught at about
only 25% of educational programs
so the challenge is to take this
bioinformatics language the language of
data science and the data about biology
so the language of biology molecular
biology cell biology and to bring those
together into an integrated
bioinformatics research experience and
provided for
and students in an integrated way so
that they're not a data science course
in a computational course on on
programming and are and then a separate
lab experience about generating the data
and RNA and DNA and the genes but it's
an integrated course and the challenge
really consists of two major parts and
so let me go through these challenges
and then talk about how we could address
these challenges so first of all to
develop such an integrated course you
really need high quality professionals
that are willing to lead and to service
it's not enough to have people that are
willing to do bioinformatics research
and take that research to a level of
publications and grants and independent
ideas because ultimately they also need
to go back and serve the other projects
that might not be as interesting in
terms of computer science computational
biology and bioinformatics the second
one is really the costs of establishing
and maintaining computational
infrastructure so a bioinformatics
department really services a lot of
projects they need computational
infrastructure that is dedicated for
those purposes but that infrastructure
needs to be developed maintained and
that is costly and and you can see that
in terms of budget the two main big
portions of that typical bioinformatics
department budget is staff and
infrastructure right
and the other aspect the other big
portion of the costs and the challenges
are really around training up and
developing internal talent to be able to
address the challenges and so this is a
lack of qualified trainers that have the
experience in both computational and
biological aspects it's difficult to
find people that have the both sides of
that of that paradigm and then you have
a lack of an easy to adopt curriculum so
there's a lot of books about
bioinformatics there's a lot of courses
and technical resources out there but
there's not really a plug-and-play
curriculum
that is tested and customizable to
address specific interests and needs in
a integrated course and then also
there's an intimidating list of
prerequisites so if a student is
potentially interested he's faced with
knowing statistics and then knowing our
being proficient in our and then knowing
how to script in Linux and all of these
different requisites and for a biologist
that's a major hurdle a lot of times
people tend to choose not to even take a
course in bioinformatics because of
these prerequisites so how can we
address these challenges and this need
and prepare something that is scaleable
that is practical and that really
develops good skills for students so
first of all it's learning by doing
right so these are some principles that
we came up with that became a part of
our course that we are piloting now at
University of Loyola number one learn by
doing so dive into bioinformatics from
the very first day you start doing
bioinformatics taking datasets
analyzing datasets interpreting datasets
number two online discussions so it's
very difficult to bring people together
it's requires a lot of time but people
do spend a lot more time online today
and so we enabled this process of
discussions to share experiences and
issues with analysis to be able to ask
those questions of experience by
informaticians and review that and
reflect on their doing process then its
ability to generalize so not only some
niche project that you focus on and you
only do that project for two years its
ability to learn skills and one set of
projects and then apply them to other
types of projects where you understand
both the opportunities and the
limitations of the approaches that you
have been doing and then finally it is
applying those skills that you have
developed in a new way
to understand real-life situations and
that is to have a continuity and after
your project after you've done a project
a test project an educational project to
be able to launch your own research and
I think you know bioinformatics provides
a unique opportunity it's a very
different setting than let's say
molecular biology where you have to
collect samples and prepare those
samples and then do something really
there's a lot of data a lot of resources
out there that you can just tap into and
you can conduct your own research
because only a small portion of the data
that today is available in repositories
is fully analyzed and then of course
doing that all over again right so going
back and taking you on a different data
type learning about RNA seek learning
about DNA seek learning about mass spec
data structural biology data integration
so all of that process could continue
how do we do this technically so first
of all a big resource that is allowing
us to do this efficiently is the T Byron
for platform the platform that was
designed for scientific research allows
performing complex data processing and
analysis pipeline without coding and so
here we are really lowering the bar for
entry people without any coding
background can enter and try out very
complex and computationally intensive
pipelines run them through see what the
outputs are and understand how they
might be useful not only that the
platform is visual interactive every
button that you see it comes with a
pop-up and the pop-up both explains what
the button does the algorithm and also
provides more resources to learn about
the algorithm typically a publication
and a summary of what you will find it
useful for in the same interface that
you see here is applied for many
different data types so you have all
kinds of next-generation sequencing data
pipelines mass spec pipelines structural
biology data integration and dedicated
sections for biology
and other unique sets of challenges and
so what's good about this is that you
have a dedicated section that is
compiling the right kinds of tools
around an area or a data type or an
application for that data and for those
analyses now in parallel with this
online platform we also have a set of
online courses and it's an online
learning environment that is all focused
around bioinformatics it has a number of
courses for example transcriptomics one
so transcriptomics one would go through
how to take raw task you file x'
next generation sequencing files process
those files and get a table of
expression transcriptomics to then picks
it up from there goes over a review of
how that is done in a pipeline you can
do it and then finally text talks about
differential gene expression in t-test
statistics and what that means and
transcriptomics three machine learning
for transcriptomics data how do you take
the table of expression and work with
the table of expression to classify
samples or to know which features are
most informative for classifications of
feature selection etc and so all of
these are central centered around an
individual the student the student sees
the progress can monitor their test
results can see how he compares to other
participants in a course and then of
course we have an online chat and so any
questions or challenges he can ask the
person and the person as a trained by
informatician that will answer it from
an experience perspective now these
basic skills prepare students to take on
projects and here you see in a number of
example projects that we've prepared
these projects have curated data sets
that were designed around specific
skills and they also expose the student
to a real research environment so not
only do you have the data you have the
publication about the data you need to
be able to learn from that publication
and so for example when you take a
project like this
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer using multiple types of cell
lines and therapeutic agents what you
really get here is a data set that is
fairly complex it was taken from a
number of other publications and then
published as a meta-analysis and so we
offer a small portion of that as an
educational data set and then provide
the full project and that project could
be done independently by a student with
their own research question behind it
currently we are doing workshops and we
are preparing other projects and other
courses that are published online a lot
of these resources are free some of them
are paid and some of them are done in
collaboration with other university
researchers and Industry and now we are
giving these workshops and guest
lecturers presenting the opportunity to
implement this curriculum design it in
such a way that it fits the needs of
different levels of students we have
over 2,000 students enrolled online we
presented the solution in a number of
places including Georgetown and weiu a
couple of universities in Nebraska here
in Louisiana at LSU Tulane University of
New Orleans and we have been selected to
present at various startup competitions
at the same time I want to mention that
April 17 and 20 we are starting our
online workshops the first workshop is
going to be at University of Nebraska
Medical Center and it's going to be
jointly certified as a participant as a
participation certificate it's going to
be a three-hour workshop on
next-generation datas sequencing
analysis data analysis from NGS data and
it will touch on topics like processing
data quality control of the data
analyzing the transcript the
transcriptome analyzing the expression
levels using machine learning methods
and then also looking at various
biomedical applications of
the data analysis and the following
workshop that we're gonna have is going
to be at university of nebraska-lincoln
all the same topics but more catering to
engineering students finally I want to
point out that we have this pilot and
dr. Kim mix who has been leading this
pilot with over 12 students from various
backgrounds in various departments and
she has an exciting program that
combines various aspects of molecular
biology and genetics and incorporating
data science for those students as a way
to prepare them for careers after they
complete the course and we are very
excited about this project it's still an
ongoing pilot but all the students have
shown interest in continuing to learn
about bioinformatics continuing to learn
bioinformatics and after completing the
course they will actually present their
independent project to the faculty for
evaluation and for feedback so this is
in short our approach to bioinformatics
our approach to incorporating
bioinformatics into a biology curriculum
I think this is a very flexible way it
could also be adapted to the research
interests of faculty so that faculty
research and education go hand in hand
and I'm constantly posting more
information about these projects and
others and you can find Pine biotech on
all the social media platforms as well
as you can look at some of these free
courses that are available online
just visit edu dot T - bio info thank
you